before we start i'm going to put a real
big disclaimer right up front
do not do
anything i talk about in this video
all of the machines i'm dealing with
here either i own them or have full
permission from the person who owns them
so
absolutely do not copy anything i'm
doing here unless you own the machines
or have permission
absolutely don't try this at home do not
do not try this at home
only try this at home oh yeah that's a
very good try this at home but not
anywhere else at all
what we're going to look at today is i
guess we could call it how to hack
out of a computer you've got a few
videos about things like
sql injection and how to get into
computers but now let's imagine
um
you're on a train in an airport or on
some network
where the administrator is not giving
you full access so you go to watch your
favorite computer file video on youtube
and the network's not letting you into
youtube
what could you do about that let's
introduce the concepts that we need to
think about so let's get the
ohp
okay so let's start and think about some
kind of basic setup so here is
a crude drawing of a laptop
and
you're connected
into
a network here
you want to access
the internet over here but
here is
our animator today
the fire wall
all right so there
your only way out of the network
is via
this firewall
and the system administrator
can put
various restrictions on there so let's
imagine
if you're on a train in the uk
the bandwidth is horrible because it's
got to go via cell phone mass and it's
changing about what it's connected to
so they typically on a train in the uk
they're not going to allow you to watch
youtube because that will take up the
entire bandwidth for the entire train
right so that firewall
will be set to block
that site
and
so this will have a bunch of blocking
rules
and that can be a variety of things we
might say
we'll block a particular site we might
say we'll block a particular port
remember this abstraction of a port it's
what transmission control protocol uses
uh to determine
where connection between two computers
which application we connect to
so
http web
is on one port secure web https is on
another port
ssh which you use to connect into a
computer once to another port
and those rules might
block
um
a particular site or they might block a
particular service so they might say
you can't connect to your email server
or they might say you can't connect to
ssh something like that
port 80's default web browsing and port
443 is default secure
web browsing nowadays almost everything
is over https
and if you see something running http
that's pretty old-fashioned so for the
purposes of this demo i've set up a
machine belonging to a friend of mine so
this is going to be living somewhere on
the internet
and
this is our kind of target machine here
so it's a machine called twisted i've
set up a little
test web page on it not even a web page
now the curl command is just a text way
of browsing the web it's just a text way
of grabbing a web page
and this is just saying
grab from
this machine twisted
the page saying test
and we get back this hello computer file
viewers this is a test to show that we
can access this file
right
all pretty simple
now
let's imagine
we are the
uh system administrator
and we're going to start messing about
with the firewall so i'm using linux
this'll work more or less the same on
macintosh the firewalls are pretty much
the same the world over
uh it's only the syntax were different
so this one is ufw i think it's ultimate
firewall very uh exciting name um
let's have a look at what it's doing so
far so
whoops mistaking the password because
this is my home machine and there's
actually there's no way into this
machine anyway
it's just it's denying
three different things all related to
mail service allowing anything else
so what if we say
let's block off
that website we wanted to go to
so i can very simply add in
a rule
to block some ports off
i'm going to deny outgoing traffic
that's the ip address
of the server i'm trying to contact and
i block off https and i block off http
and if you look at our firewall status
it's denying to that ip address
it's denying outgoing traffic
to http port 80 and https port 443
so now
in theory we can't get any web traffic
through to that website so let's try
again our command to get that web page
we're trying to get it we're trying to
get it and it's timed out i hope i've
convinced you that me the nasty system
administrator has blocked myself from
accessing that website the question is
how can we get around that there's quite
a few ways
one of them
is to use ssh
now
ssh is
the command we use not the normal use of
ssh is just to log into a machine so if
i do ssh
richard richardplague.org
that'll simply
connect me to my remote server yeah
that's the normal
use of it it sets up a cryptographically
secure connection
from one machine to another so i've
connected from my home machine
barcentine to my
server richardclub.org that's how you
send your files to me as well isn't it
yeah that is actually yes ssh and
scp that's how i transfer the video over
to sean for it to do the magic and try
and make me look good and edit out all
the bits where i've gone erm but there's
lots and lots of things you can do with
this ssh it's a generic way once you've
got that
ssh connection open
we can do a few things with that
so here
i'm going to add in a few little things
to that command
so i'm going to tell it
minus f do that in the background
n
we don't want it to
execute any particular command
and
this one this minus d1080
this is going to take a little bit of
explanation but what that says is for
the ssh command it says
listen on the local computer on port 108
and any traffic you now get to port
i want you to push that traffic
down the tunnel yeah down the ssh and
have it come out the other end
so now what we've achieved is anything
that i send to port 1080
on my local machine
we'll go down this tunnel
and come out at the other end on my
remote server on richardglad.org
yeah
what we've kind of done here
is we've built let's have a richard
clegg.org on there i'll just put richard
for short and what we've done is
we've built a little ssh
tunnel
and that's listening on port
108 oh
so anything i push to port 1080 on my
local machine
that's going to spit out
on this machine here okay so what's the
point of that
we can use that
as a proxy we can pretend that that
is our web service so for example if i
do this
that says to the curl command
so i've got this socks5 it's what we
call a socks proxy it's saying there's a
raw socket
there's a raw port that we can push data
down and it will act
as if it's a connection it will act as
if it's a tunnel
uh into this machine so now
i'm saying instead of going directly to
this machine i want you to go
via that
socks proxy and we can actually we can
set our whole machine
to use this we can go into settings
except for proxy and we can say 27.0.0.1
report 1080
is
going to be
a proxy host
so now if i do this
my web browser is also using that proxy
host and my web browser is going
via
this
ssh tunnel
to access the site that's the very
simplest way we could get around this
problem if you're on a macintosh you can
do something similar
if you're on windows you can use a
program called putty to do something
very similar there's actually
a really cute little problem with this
and if you do this you find your
connection becomes incredibly
quirky your connection becomes really
unreliable
and there's a nice little reason why
that is because what we're doing is
this ssh tunnel
uses
tcp
yeah
so tcp
is
a lossless protocol tcp
ensures
that
packets that are lost
are re-transmitted
okay
and that's fine that's tcp's job
but we're doing a really strange thing
here with the socks proxy because what
we're doing is
we're now inserting a second tcp session
but it's going
over
this tunnel
the tcp over tcp tcp over tcp
so the tcp is being carried
by the extra section which is also tcp
things in this tunnel
now
can't be lost
yeah because the tunnel itself is
providing reliability now you might
think well that sounds great richard we
don't want things to be lost
double reliability yeah we've got double
it must be twice as good super reliable
right
the problem is
that tcp actually
relies on loss
tcp doesn't work well without loss
because tcp
uses loss
to tell
when it's too congested
the only way that tcp knows that a
network is congested
is when packets are lost
so there's another thing we can do so
i'll just kill off
my tcp tunnel
now instead there's a really nice
program uh called s shuttle which wraps
up
all of this
tunneling nonsense into one
uh quite convenient program so
it's brilliant it takes care of the tcp
properly so we're not doing that
horrible tcp over tcp thing which should
offend anyone who's studied congestion
control you should be really horrified
by tcp over tcp
so
s shut up really simple command here
this is saying
s shuttle to the remote server
richieque.org
any traffic on this machine destined for
any of this particular address block
uh is going to go through that tunnel
and this will just take care on a
limited view that will take care of any
traffic destined for anything beginning
178 2576 as an ip address and it will
take care
of
ensuring it goes through
that tunnel
so we've got to wait a bit for that to
set
up and
then
just do an ssh in and i can connect in
even though port 22 is blocked and the
only access i have is a proxy server we
can get in like that if you wanted the
one line of how to do it
if you were
on a place where it allowed um
where you had access to
ssh and you had your own server
that's that s shuttle
is a brilliant way of doing it
if you're the system administrator you
might think well i've still got a few
things i can play with here because
you're a system administrator you've got
a lot of power in this system one thing
we could do is block off ssh
yeah you could say well hold on if
you're going to use ssh for shenanigans
let's make sure you can't do that
again there's a real
simple response to that
so if you're
if you're running
your own server
you can say fine you've blocked off ssh
what i'm going to do is
i'm gonna make my ssh work on another
server so here
we're just telling this server this is
the richard clegg server
and we're just saying to it
make
port 444 act as my ssh server
we added that rule
and now
we can ssh
to port
actually probably can't because i
probably haven't opened port 444 um
[Music]
okay so we feed it fed in the gap in the
firewall for us so that's a server i
control and now
we can run that ssh we can run it across
port 444 and even if the system
administrator blocks off port 22 we can
still get it
now if you if you are actually
wanting to make
a
site if you actually wanted to make a
network really secure
you don't have
default open ports
you close down everything
yeah
and if you want to make a site really
secure
you don't allow people to directly
access port 80 you don't allow open
access to port 80 anyway
you use a web
proxy let me draw out that more
secure system for you
in our hypothetical scenario this
richard clegg machine
this is our web
proxy our system administrator is really
locking things down and they're going to
block
everything
there's one or two things you have to
allow and if you want people to be able
to browse the web you need to
allow some access so what you need to
allow is
access to the web proxy the only thing
that we're going to allow
the person to get to is the web proxy
and that web proxy then you can say yeah
and that web proxy is only going to
carry certain sites and they're going to
carry on a loud list of sites
okay so can we now
get to our target machine up here
the twisted machine this is a little bit
more challenging i mean to be honest
actually when i was
messing about trying to do this it took
me quite a while to get this one working
the basic thing we can do here is use
the web proxy
to bounce
our
ssh
yeah
so i'm not going to explain
too much about this but i will on the
way
i just want to explain one command this
this command
is so
useful in networking it's not as well
known as it should be and this netcat
command is gorgeous to work with it's so
useful for testing and making sure that
machines are working
and it's just a way of generically
allowing you to listen
on a port
and wait for a connection and send
traffic to this port so it works in
pairs so i'll open up another gap in my
firewall i am going to shut these after
the video
so
that's added a port
to listen on
and this says listen on 2 2 2 2
and then from my home machine
so i type hello there
and it comes up that may not seem like
much but that is so
useful for testing your network for
making sure
that those particular ports are open
but also this is now it's become a
generic way
so i could for example
i could look at my
web server and see what happens if i say
hello to a web server
and it said that hello is a bad request
because that's not a language that web
servers speak yeah
um
we need to get working on that i think
yeah yeah
i'm not sure i think probably sticking
with uh http is is good for the old web
server there that's a bit of an aside
but i think people who don't know the
netcat command they're really missing
out because it's really really a very
very useful command so what i've done is
i've made this richard clegg.org machine
act
as a web proxy i have to do a little
cheat here because i don't have
root access on that twisted machine
so what i'm going to do
is tell
my proxy server
whenever something exits on port 443
i'm going to map it back to port 22. so
that is how
this command looks here and this is
saying anything going to this twisted
machine
is going to be routed
to port
22.
this proxy command will use so we use
ssh and we tell it
we'll tell it to use a proxy via the nc
command
via the richardclag.org
proxy so this
richard.org 3128
is a proxy server listening on 3128
and if we do that we can now
get our traffic
through
the proxy
and into toy box or trying to make an
ssh connection but
on port
4 three it's coming over here
and
there's a little bit of a cheat here
where i'm going to map that port 443
back to a port 22 which is the correct
port for ssh
and it's going to arrive here
at the ssh daemon
and we can respond and we've got our ssh
tunnel set up again
so even though the system administrator
only allowed access to the
authorized web tunnel
we were still able to get an ssh
connection through and do all that
tunneling
there's actually there's some really
weird and wonderful varieties of this
tunneling you can do
so we've talked before about a ping
command
and
the ping command was the command that
let us
send out a test to see if a server is
working
and we can actually add
traffic into that ping command
and use that to send our tunneling so i
can add a little bit of informational
messages onto the ping
and use that to transmit information
but my very favorite one of this this is
lovely is
tunneling over dns
domain
name service
so this is a a
really interesting way of tunneling data
so domain name services job is to say
if i tell you there is a machine called
computerfile.org
the main name service is the part of the
system
that
converts that to an internet protocol
address yeah
if you're the system administrator of
computerfile.org
and you want you want a little extra way
to get around networks you can
subvert that domain name service system
so it's your system
that's ultimately responsible for
returning the correct ip address for
computerfile.org
now
what you can do is you can also you
could also have
shawn.computerfile.org
or
mynewserver.com.org
data i want to transmit computer
file.org
and what's going to happen is the dns
system will eventually
pass that request
data i want to transmit dot
computerfile.org that will eventually
get to the dns router you are using and
now
you've got that data from the system so
you've established a path
where you can transmit data even if the
only thing the system administrator is
allowing
is domain name service you need domain
name service
so um
there's a
system called iodine
that will
allow you to tunnel
these things over dns
um
i've not tried it myself because it
takes quite a bit of setup
but it's a really cute idea i was uh
intrigued by the um
i was intrigued by the level of
ingenuity that went into that one so we
now know how to tunnel our way out
we now know how to lower in a variety of
circumstances we now know how to tunnel
out the network but let me convince you
why this is a terrible idea
so okay
if you're on a train at an airport
you might get away with it you're
violating their terms of service but if
you're doing this
on a on a in a place where the system
administrator has locked things down
well enough that the only way to get out
of the system is through a web proxy and
they are
only allowing you to access some sites
there are probably an awful lot of
alarms and tripwires they're probably
monitoring
that system very closely so i spoke to a
few friends who do
web security stuff in the real world
which i certainly don't do i'm an
academic
and they said yeah it should but
we would catch those people really
quickly
because if you think about a web proxy
what you typically do to a web proxy you
send a command all right please give me
this website let's send you the website
back
what i'm doing in abusing that web proxy
i'm setting up a long-lived connection
that will be there for
many many minutes or even hours
that's instantly suspicious
all right so instead of this this
connection being there and gone that
connection is lasting hours
if a company is really serious about
security they've got proper endpoint
monitors on those computers and in any
case they're probably not going to let
you install arbitrary software like this
shuffle on your computer anyway
well the other thing my friend said to
me
it's quite compelling reason is he said
if you're on my system trying to hack
your white out
maybe you'll be lucky some days
uh maybe you'll be looking once or twice
but if you're not going to be caught you
have to be lucky every single time
and i only have to be lucky once to
catch you
to me that that's a very compelling
argument for not doing any of this
values are kind of the same
i mean they're not they're pretty close
that's a little bit darker perhaps
because the blue's a bit stronger
considering you've done that without
actually measuring anything yeah i mean
obviously that starts to happen
the traffic's just going to carry on
going around in that loop
you've got big problem